mariah carey is indeed divorce from Nick  Cannon a source confirms to ET their  divorce was finalized just days before  the singer split from billionaire James  Packer the source tells us Mariah and  James plan to marry in the new year they  had gone to Greece to talk wedding plans  after her divorce from Nick was  finalized after the two called it quits  last week each he has also learned  mariah wants to keep the 35 carat  engagement ring her billionaire fiance  gave her when he proposed back in  January a source says the two are  discussing plans on how to move forward  with the breakup but Mimi is keeping the  ring after being blindsided by the split  as for Nick et caught up with him in  July he slammed rumours he was holding  up his exs wedding to James I wish it  was that easy or you could just find  something be like I've done but it's a  lot of things that go with that they are  beyond my control